hello today we're going to be exploring
the subject of analog horror if you
don't know what analog horror is
remember my video maple county that was
an example of it analog horror is a
genre or a sub-genre that exists in the
world of the era of the vhs
kind of a little bit so analog is
relating to or using signals or
information represented by a
continuously variable physical quantity
such as spatial positioning voltage etc
or analog a person or thing seen as
comparable to another which is oddly
interesting oddly interesting it's
interesting oddly enough the oddly thing
is that that is interesting
that is interesting because it pertains
to what we're talking about today
and the alternates the alternates are
kind of the idea behind
um if you remember
this video
this video the mandela catalog this is
made
by a one alex kister we are currently
receiving countless reports of an
unidentified hostile organism that will
refer to as alternates a lot of them
from what i've seen start from this
informational type of video which is
this is actually like 1950s propaganda
videos from the government to tell you
how to survive an atomic bomb that's the
kind of videos that i get the vibe of so
this is not just analog in the days of
vhs this is old analog in the terms of
archival footage and stuff like that you
know things that are so far in the past
but baked into the subconscious because
they are effectively propaganda and
they're supposed to be baked into the
subconscious to get you to think one way
or another so to use this as a medium to
tell story that is a horror story is an
effective use because the technology is
inherently jank and kind of the horror
comes from it being jank and also the
information being presented to you that
there is an entity that looks just like
you that is trying to take over your
life and when it finds you it will make
an almost perfect facility of you or it
has already made a perfect fast simile
of your parents or loved ones or friends
or neighbors or
colleagues they could be anyone
anywhere
at any time
even me
but i'm not
so let's look into analog horror because
there's so much more to analog horror
than just the mandela catalog or maple
county do not believe his lies the
mandela catalog
ass film theorists that you know you do
you do
professional research i'm here to do my
research which is because i say it in a
more authoritative tone
i'm gonna
i'm gonna let people assume that i know
what i'm talking about which i have not
been able to say properly this whole
video let me look at something that i
found which is called blue channel
thalassin
or a loved one are suffering from any of
the following symptoms lack of feeling
emotional outbursts fog of the mind or
memory loss this may be a sign of onset
aed or advanced emotional deterioration
today 7 in 10 people over the age of 21
report experiencing emotional
degradation severe enough to hinder
everyday tasks such as workplace
performance social interaction and
general well-being
emotional stability is required for a
functional and healthy mind
correcting aed used to require rigorous
testing and invasive procedures costing
time effort and money
today the solution is thousand
[Music]
using our modern understanding of brain
mapping ballistic is able to reproduce
the emotions necessary for any occasion
not only does thallison restore lost
emotion but patients have reported
emotions at a higher and more consistent
quality than once produced
non-chemically
included in every pack of thallism are
these common emotions
happiness
sadness
anger
fear and relief
also look out for over-the-counter
options such as jealousy hope
frustration and pride
[Music]
tired of only experiencing where's the
horny option or may be interested in
expanding your emotional palate
cutting-edge brain mapping technology
has not only allowed us to refine
existing emotions but has also allowed
for the creation of new emotions
and emotional experiences
with this
experience emotions beyond previous
natural capabilities
these new emotions include degrees
humber
mage
to experience the power of the sin call
the number on your screen now before
supplying that's where those pictures
came from there was a post on reddit
like forever ago that was a picture of
those emotions and it was like a big
post and i thought they made it that's
how things don't like if it doesn't get
credited it doesn't go anywhere and i
don't know who makes it goose works i've
seen those before my god
grantedness i love to luge i wanna
experience to luge uh like a
heaping helping of toulouge mixed with a
little bit of uh
just online lauric they didn't even
mention the online
i want some online
loric anyway this is like
well done goose works uh really fun
stuff but yeah no that's another example
of what analog horror is
it's like an old this blue
screen has such a strong
my memory it may not have the same
impact in your memory
encoding delay
why that seems to be fine yeah so this
is the kind of concept behind analog
horror a lot of things exist in this
world and there's actually a playlist
that someone named the analog collector
has made that kind of collects a lot of
different analog horror things
sun says chimpy chippa's band commercial
okay what is this
okay lads let's take this from the top
do you want to know what's driving
everyone bananas well come on down to
chimpy chippers enjoy our wide range of
milkshakes burgers and fries and have
you coming back for more are you as
excited as the
[Music]
[ __ ] sorry sorry bloody monkey just who
cares just
we're going to do it again just give me
another go from the top
you want to know what's driving your
word
and chimpy chippers and our iconic
chimpy cheeseburger dudes with that on
our weekly specials so what are you
waiting for because chipper the chimp is
waiting for you
look i know you guys spent time on
making this monkey thing but has no one
realized how [ __ ] creepy it looks or
is it just me
because i can tell you right now i'd
never take my daughter
so i i'd say i'd say i'd say this is an
example of something that
isn't necessarily one of the scariest
things i've ever seen
in fact personally i didn't think it was
scary at all however i'm not here to
just [ __ ] all over springtalk pictures
creations that's not what i'm here about
i i want to dissect why this doesn't
work and the other ones work really well
because i i know there's a video
not this one every analog horror video
here we go
this year we're celebrating 35 years in
business did you know we've come up with
six all new value combo coupons and if
you sign up for our email club you'll
save 15 off
well that's a little
that's a little on the nose
[Music]
okay so funny whatever whatever it's a
parody but i think like if a good parody
needs to understand the exact essence of
what does work for something even if
you're making fun of it you need to
understand why it works for the people
that it works for to get there and this
kind of does that yeah one second what
is this oh i s did i watch this one i
think this might be the one i was
thinking of
[Music]
foreign
okay
so
okay so this is an example of a good
parody right it knows what it's making
fun of i think the comments are just
like you when your parody is so well
made it wraps around to being scary
again that's kind of what it is because
that was by itself unsettling and analog
horror can be really unsettling if it's
done right and you can do a parody
that's so good that it does wrap around
all the way to unsettling by the way
this is a great video how audio enhances
the horror five nights at freddy's great
video the other thing that i want to
show you is
something that kind of goes beyond just
analog horror there's a video by the
mystery flesh pit
guy girl i don't know the person who
does the mystery flesh pit also has a
youtube channel i don't know if you knew
this is called mystery flush bit
national pork park park historic archive
and the first video that they ever put
out was this one and this one's just
like it's fascinating because it is
technically i think in the genre of
analog horror but then again the whole
premise of the mystery flesh pit which
if you don't know about you should look
it up is kind of in the same vein as why
this analog horror as a concept is scary
it's something rooted in the past
because the story of the mystery flesh
pit is all told from the perspective of
articles and memorabilia and little
informational placards that are from the
era of when the mystery flesh pit
existed and before the disaster of the
mystery flesh bit and so you uncover the
universe through in-universe clues that
occurred after the event occurred
and this is one of them
[Music]
the following messages transmitted at
the request of the texas department of
public safety the united states
geological survey and the permian basin
recovery corporation the united states
geological survey has issued a
geobiological activity advisory for the
following counties coke county gumption
county howard county midland county
sterling county
2 18 am central daylight times at 10 48
p.m
central daylight time seismic ekg
monitoring stations detected muscle
contractions originating from the
northeastern loom of the permian basin
super organism this event is expected to
cause moderate to severe damage to
property utility services and
infrastructure residents are advised to
seek shelter immediately
[Music]
during this event you may experience
headaches nausea fever hallucinations
dizziness mild seizures temporary
changes in vision they do store enhanced
cognitive ability limited precognition
memory loss and muscle cramps these
effects are temporary and will stop once
the event has concluded
so this this is cool right this came out
uh december of 2020 it is now 2022 so
this was over a year ago this is
actually before a lot of these analog
horror videos came out it's not the
first analogue or thing by a long shot
but it is one of the earlier ones and it
has a great example of why it and a lot
of the analog horror things work so well
it's something that you know even if
it's an emergency you know
this screen you know this and because
you know it even if it's something bad
you can be used to it and you can
understand it however there's already
strange things that are happening in
this emergency broadcast that really
mark it out as something that you should
pay attention to and something that is
not what you expect and that is the
basis of what makes it so kind of creepy
because it's unsettling because it's
something that you expect to know and
it's not what it is it's not a tornado
warning it's not a like a earthquake
warning no it's
geobiological activity advisory that
makes you go what the [ __ ] is that you
don't know what that is but you know
those words geobiological so okay
geological biological something that's
on the scale of geology and biology
that's
weird at first and that's like the whole
reason why the mystery flesh bit works
so well but also just like the rest of
it going on as it continues the fact
that it is a recording of a screen and
you have the environmental things
happening that are kind of coinciding
with the mess that is being relayed and
it's rooted in reality right it's rooted
in reality and that's kind of the bigger
point of it like it's it's rooted in
something that could potentially be real
you see these counties you know roughly
the size of what a county is in a state
if you're from america this thing
whatever the frick it is
it it's
so big and you hear them talking about
how there's an activity warning off the
northeastern limb of the permian basin
superorganism all of these are pretty
much new words to anybody that's ever
read english and grew up knowing english
all of these are pretty new but you know
the combinations of them and you know
the basis of the context that you're
getting it and all of them spell bad
news so this event is expected to cause
moderate to severe damage also like
understating what it could possibly do
and just like the list of things and the
things happening in the noise like you
could say a lot about the production
quality and like the different things
and the actual realism of it but the
fact that it is there and this happening
all aids to the idea that it's kind of
real that's the other thing about analog
core it taps into this thing where you
don't know if it's not real you can play
a lot of horror games and you can know
that they're not real because you're
playing a game but when you're watching
an informational video like this you
don't automatically know that it's not
real if you've never been exposed to
something like this before and that also
is what makes analog horror really
creepy you don't know if this
informational broadcast about people
that aren't people that kind of look
like people
is real or not you know that it's
probably not real but it seems presented
in a way that could be real especially
if it's like that game maple county that
is a police instructional video and
someone would only go to the trouble of
making an instructional video if it was
something that actually needed to be
instructed right so there's a sense of
realism there and then you get these
things like you might experience
headaches nausea okay fever
hallucinations okay dizziness mild
seizures okay temporary changes in
vision reduced or enhanced cognitive
abilities like
limited precognition like these things
like lumping the reel in with the not
real i think is what really
hones in this idea kind of hiding the
unreal in the real and that's what makes
mystery flesh pits so cool is because
there's so much unreal buried in real of
what it could potentially be and like
that kind of like twisting of reality is
where this gets cool now with this with
allison like the attrantiveness
it's it's great well this isn't the
original one it's great because it
starts out with something that is kind
of crazy but you're like okay that's
that's kind of funky you know a medicine
that gives you emotions okay all right i
get it not scary by itself but it
already set up a universe where it could
then put dorslessness into it freaking
dorslessness
so i think that that's kind of like my
101 about why analog horror is what it
is and why it can
work so what i'm gonna do now is watch
some analog horror videos what kid's
safety tips what's this andy living good
the church of the future
fun and safety tips
after school safety what do you do when
a stranger approaches you
don't speak to them do not go with them
run away and tell an adult you trust
okay good advice so far
what do you do when your parents come to
pick you up is it really your parents
look for their eyes
see the light
listen to them speak
do you hear the scratching
let them take you somewhere fun
playtime safety
do not hide in places where you can get
trapped places like old refrigerators
can seal you in that's no fun
hide in fun places like the doorway
keep your mouth open do not close your
eyes they live inside the doorway you
will have fun
you will laugh and laugh
you will stay
[Music]
home safety
after your parents tuck you in open your
window
children should not sleep with their
windows closed
when you hear the voices go with them to
the doorway
it will be a fun game
oh all right
okay ow
so this was not bad but i think this is
one of those ones that leans too hard
too quickly and isn't rooted in enough
reality because i think it was good
there with like don't talk to strangers
but it was like already presented in a
weird way that made it seem like
disturbing and wrong and i don't think
that works out as well as it could if it
was something that was more basic
uh from the get-go or not more basic but
more
like i said rooted in reality and was
kind of like
like it's one of those things where less
is more right
in horror
if you show the monster i don't know
what this is if you show the monster it
ruins any potential scare of the unknown
right because you know it and as soon as
you know something you know what it is
all right well
good job you just fell over i think
another good example of analog horror or
at least kind of this genre i don't know
if they would want to be lumped in with
this but
if you remember discover my body so this
game i played a while ago if you haven't
seen it go check it out the game itself
is very creepy so the the reason that
was so creepy is because of the way that
he makes things it harkens the design of
analog horror with like a lot of
pixelation and a lot of like uncertainty
about what you're seeing a lot of old
technology and stuff like that but
there's just like a certain blend of it
that uh
i think his name is james does that
really combines a lot of elements that i
love about analog or
and puts it into a package that
is just an overall very creepy thing but
the thing about discover my body and if
you go watch that video that i did of it
or go play the game yourself better yet
it's presented like it's normal and i
think that's the key so when you get to
the part where he's starting to flower
other brains off of like his bones or
something
he's acting like it's perfectly normal
the incredible pain of that other step
where he just starts screaming is
presented like it's perfectly normal and
it's all part of the plan and if there's
a plan then you can follow the plan and
you can survive but if you don't follow
the plan
they're going to find you and you will
be defenseless against them
so just stick to the plan and everything
will be just fine
and that's what makes things scary i
didn't point out anything specifically
of that that makes things scary but the
combination of it should be pretty
obvious anyway what i want to do is i
want to go to uh some more of this um
mandela catalog because i really liked
what was going on with the mandela
catalog like i don't know if it was like
the best made but i kind of want to look
at some other things around there okay
this is exhibition it's a longer one
[Music]
am i looking at
what did i just see oh my god
i was just skipping through this a
little bit i just saw
that you know i don't like that
i'm not gonna lie i don't like that and
that's very simple but at the same time
i don't like it i think that's analog
horror you just look at it and go i
don't like it i don't like that could i
have less of that please and then it
gives you more of that right that's what
it does
anyway this is like sum up
it will be your last message
listen can you crank that up for me make
it more legible uh uh hearable
what
the death of mark i i saw the death of
mark did you see the death of mark i saw
the death of mark
analog television and mirrors all right
so that's the story don't look at analog
tvs no crts around here
all right cool
hang on
let's face it us parents know how time
consuming it is to keep an eye on our
young children while working is
essential they must receive attention
from us so that they know we love them
too
some of us may rely on key things that
keep them entertained like toys
walks in a stroller
or even cartoons on the family
television
be cautious with what channels your
children view on the television since
you never know what harmful content they
may be seeing
your children may be viewing elements of
violent content
sexual content
graphic content
scary imagery
if you hear your child screaming or
crying in front of the television wait
until your child stops making noise
before entering the room
i know what to do in this situation
nothing
what good parent am i
[Music]
i don't see no baby
hi
hey
hey you've taken some dilemma and
whatever it is
hello
every time how did i know this was gonna
happen
every time so
that ends my exploration of analog
horror there's a lot of different things
that you can do with analog core it
doesn't all have to be transitiveness
doesn't all have to be talluge or
onland
doesn't have to be that or loric or any
of these or even dorslessness but it's
fun and it's hard to get right but it's
a cool genre sub genre whatever it's
cool and also if you didn't hear me
talking about this on distractible um
there's a subreddit called distressing
memes that has a little bit of this
feeling we didn't talk about analog
horror on the podcast if you want to get
the episode i'll link it in the
description below where we talk about
this it's a really good episode um it's
just like distressing memes
oh
no
see this is exactly what i was talking
about the alternates and stuff [ __ ] like
that but distressing memes is is great
like legitimately we go in depth in this
on uh the podcast link is in the
description but it's just this [ __ ] you
know
[Music]
anyway
it's just
it's just this yeah
oh yeah
[Music]
anyway having fun memes so cool but
that's the same thing right you know
what a meme is even if you don't find
memes funny on general basis but it's
just like taking that concept of what
you know and turning it around into
something that you are
unsure of and is unsettling is great it
has the energy of uh me and the boys at
2am looking for beans like
i don't know why it's got that energy
but this is somehow not terrifying at
all this sounds great it sounds like a
good time but unfortunately the other
ones do not so anyway i'm done with this
video if you want to try more analog
horse stuff go look it up and go tell me
what you think is the best one and what
really dissects what it means to be
scary because it's not an easy thing to
nail down oddly enough for a guy that
has played a lot of horror games and
like i've done some spooky stuff in the
past it's not a easy thing to nail down
so thank you if you want to listen more
about our conversations about this kind
of stuff and our personal experiences of
scary stories that we have had in our
lives one of which i have actually
experienced just like a few weeks ago
where i could have sworn that i heard
amy talking to me directly in front of
me in a dark bedroom
when in fact she was all the way across
the house behind me
i could have sworn i heard her voice
from the darkness in front of me so
anyway link to that is in the
description below go down and click
right down there have fun it's a good
it's a good episode so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down in the
comments below let me know what analog
word you find and what scary things
scare you
thank you
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye